[Music]
globalized a new take on security policy
by DW we live Kate what are you doing
just say when the next iPhone's coming
out the next well yeah I missed the last
one and so I figured I'd just jump onto
the 15 I mean you've seen the the Old
Brick I've got here maybe that's a good
idea because the next one might not be
made in China I mean okay it might not
be made in India but it could be
assembled in India how is that that's
because you know Kobe and there were
lockdowns and the whole supply chain
suffered that's true and now we saw over
Christmas it was the production was
limited and so it seems like China is
missing out and other countries can't
really wait so long so maybe they are
going to look to diversify yeah and that
diversifying might be good for India
which means jobs possibly that is right
so the question we're going to ask today
is is diversifying from China creating
jobs in India all right welcome to
Global eyes where we take a deep dive
into the security policy issues
affecting your lives and our lives I'm
Isha and I'm Kate
So today we're going to talk about chips
and Wafers excuse me
not the snacks
chips and Wafers but the semiconductor
chips so they're everywhere like these
tiny things they're in our smartphones
they're in laptops washing machines
toothbrushes toothbrushes toothbrushes
imagine they're everywhere and you just
can't imagine a world without them today
so the thing is that they have become an
integral part of the functioning of any
society today and Mainland China is the
fastest growing chip producer in the
world and Taiwan is home to the most
important chip factory in the world and
it's called Taiwan semiconductor
manufacturing company or tsmc for sure I
prefer the shortened version yeah right
so now if for any reason China decides
to stop the production or if the
production stops like it happened in
covet now the whole globe is going to be
affected by that and that's the big deal
we've seen that during the pandemic in
Germany I know a lot of people who are
not able to buy cars now these huge
chunks of Steel they're actually there
but you can't use them they're useless
because those semiconductor chips
they're not there they were not coming
from China so that's the thing if people
don't diversify if the world stands
still exactly and I think now we can go
to our first guest and understand things
in a better manner I just wanted to give
a little briefing so that we know what
we're really talking about but I guess
our first case can actually make us
understand it better so let's find out
exactly what that means and it's
especially for India so let's bring in
our first guest with us now we have Mr
Arjun gargaias who's currently based in
Delhi he is an expert at high tech
geopolitics and a consultant for the
Indian ministry of electronics and
information technology thank you so much
for joining us on globalize
Hello nice to meet you and nice to be
here now Arjun has written this
wonderful paper on Silicon diplomacy and
I can highly recommend it I must say
Kate and I we really enjoyed reading it
we learned a lot of things and we also
got confused about a lot of things
and so let's start talking about the
paper first so Arjun there are a lot of
nitty-gritties like you've started the
paper with that semiconductors
transistors chips now these are terms
that we use Loosely I don't think
everybody realizes while talking about
it what they're actually talking about
so if you could just explain that first
of all so that we can put this in
perspective that what exactly is
happening in China what is happening in
Taiwan and where does India fit into
this whole picture
sure sure I mean that to give you a
primer right I think people started
talking about semiconductors and chips
uh especially during this covid-19
pandemic when there was a global
shortage but clearly the definition of a
chip a semiconductor material and all
kind of got mixed up and uh that is
where you know the policy perspective uh
for any person kind of God model uh just
to put things in perspective a
semiconductor is just an another
material it is
from the Silicon family that we can be
silicon germanium silicon carbide
then gallium nitride these are materials
which are basically in between
conductors and insulators and they help
in uh they are used as substrates or or
just like wafers in chips chips are what
we use in all our regular uh electronic
products laptop uh mobile phone uh
anything iPod basically anything which
uh we use that have a chip in it and
each chip is made of different
transistors transistor is basically the
uh component which kind of makes up
circuits so now having said that what a
semiconductor is what a chip is and what
a transistor is what is being produced
in China what is being produced in
Taiwan and where does India come in
okay so uh if you talk about the
production of a chip itself it undergoes
multiple handovers in terms of uh the
the uh the raw material which is the
semiconductor material has different
places like basically different places
have different deposits of raw materials
like China has a high deposit of silicon
and even the US so uh that is basically
the starting point of it that's the raw
material right and then uh you design
the Chip And then you manufacture the
ship so let's go buy uh like the four
basic uh phases of how you manufacture
the chips itself or how you make the
product one is the one is the raw
materials which is uh this semiconductor
materials then it's the design phase
wherein you have Engineers kind of using
softwares to place these kind of
transistors and uh um on on the chip
itself and are kind of design it in a
way that they can like communicate with
each other and then comes the
manufacturing or the fabrication but
this is where
you kind of uh use high pressure high
position materials uh High position
equipment Taiwan is the PowerHouse in
the manufacturing bit so uh in the
manufacturing phase they are the
PowerHouse in the world so they must
they manufacture over 60 percent of the
world's total chips and this is because
they run on what we call as the pure
clay Foundry model so what that is
basically is that the fact that
Taiwanese firm they they are not into
any of the other aspects of the supply
chain they just do the manufacturing
bits so they take in designs from
American firms some some South Koreans
from some Japanese firms from uh Chinese
firms and then they take the designs and
then they manufacture it and give back
the product to them so that is all they
do now China is trying to do
all aspects right so they believe in
being self-sufficient across the supply
chain but it is hard uh as we know that
each phase has different uh
kind of requirements a different kind of
expertise required so it's just the fact
that uh China has been trying to do it
and has kind of made some kind of of
gains but where they are most uh
concentrated right now is in the
assembly test and packaging aspect so
they uh they do the large part of it
after the ship is manufactured they uh
you you see big Chinese for uh factories
you know assembling products assembling
these chips I mean putting these chips
into certain uh electronic products
iPhone has I mean Apple has their uh one
of their biggest assembly uh uh like
factories in China uh so China has been
doing that itself uh and they're also
trying to get into the manufacturing
wind because they clearly know that uh
it the world is heavily dependent on
Taiwan and um they they have kind of
made their own manufacturing industry it
has um this smic is their main uh
contact manufacturer wherein they kind
of uh manufacture these chips for local
domestic semiconductor bonds so yeah I
mean that's that's the thing right now
and when it comes to India both now and
going forward what kind of role we
expecting India to play
yeah so uh India has been trying to
build a fabrication facility or a
manufacturing facility from I I let's
say almost 40 years uh it is almost from
the 1970s 80s they've been trying to do
it but so far till now they have not
been able to build a commercial
fabrication facility there there are a
few Fabs or what we call as well yeah
the same manufacturing center in India
but these are very very specific and
they cater only to the defense in the
previous space industry which is
basically the government owned uh sector
there is no commercial uh class this is
operating in the country and they've
been trying to do it but in that current
sense actually rely on the design aspect
so you you see that um Indian engineers
are the are at the Forefront of
Designing these chips these are
Electronics Engineers myself being one
and I work in a semiconductor firm
before actually transitioning into
policy so
um I I know for a fact that almost all
of the design
um from major you American firms like
U.S firms like uh Intel Qualcomm and
media AMD uh everything like even from
Taiwanese firms even from South Korean
firms such as Samsung so the all these
designs are done by Indian Engineers who
are sitting in the country so most of
these
um semiconductor firms have their design
centers in India and that is being done
by Indian Engineers itself yeah so would
you say looking ahead to the Future that
there's actually more potential in the
design side of things in the
manufacturing when it comes to India's
role because if you think of you know
it's just you were mentioning about how
you know China was trying to push to be
self-suspect self-sufficient
across this Supply eye chain
um surely you know it would take such a
long time to build up that kind of
expertise that China has in producing
models
um you know could India even go down
that route in the long term
again
so semiconductor says that fusions he's
such an ambitious thought you know like
no one has been able to achieve that not
even the biggest Tech powers in the
country not U.S not Europe not China
because each aspect of the supply chain
is so so intricate and fragile because
uh like there are so many different
things which come into the picture and
as you said uh it has taken Taiwan
almost 50 years to actually build that
semiconductor industry which is the
manufacturing bit and the csmc and UMC
which are their biggest firms which are
the contact manufacturers for Taiwan
have been you know like curated and set
up almost since the 1960s and to reach
where they have reached now it has taken
significant amount of capital investment
uh trade policy uh changes and it and
it's it's a huge it's like a it's like a
matter of it's not a Sprint and India
again having a Fab in India is always a
good thing because you can actually
manufacture for the domestic consumption
itself that is definitely there but
again like what kind of fabric is
because the high-end fats take so much
amount of like Investments to actually
set up so
that is why design itself is a low
hanging fruit for India because they
already have the talent in the country
they just do not have the semiconductor
firms most of them work for uh American
or like basically not Indian phones and
so if India can actually nurture that
talent and kind of build domestic or uh
you know domestic sector thriving sector
of semiconductor design firms that means
that India would kind of out basically
be the contract designers similarly how
Taiwan is a contract manufacturers all
the firms can actually get their designs
done by Indian firms and then they can
move on to manufacturing the chip itself
I I have to say I love the way you keep
using the word Fab I mean I've used Fab
for something else for me Fab is
fabulous right but this is fabrication
Center to put it into context and the
way you've been explaining about the
chips the semiconductor I think if there
were a mascot for globalization it
should be semiconductor just because you
can't have one country doing everything
and you've talked about India having
expertise in design but if it is just
design and if for one country to have a
production line it takes such a long
time and so much of expertise why was
India chosen if I may use the word
chosen for the billion dollar investment
uh so I think it was in December 2021
that Indian the Indian government uh the
ministry of electronics and ID came out
with the semiconductor of bad ecosystem
right one of their major major uh goals
is to get a fat in the country because
we do not have any commercial style
right now and it is hurting us naturally
because we're so totally dependent on
Imports and our biggest Imports are from
China itself and that is something that
the government wants to change in the
semiconductor industry even a billion
dollar is just Pina if you cannot set up
a high-end fabrication facility with a
billion dollars like
um uh you need immense amount of capital
to just set up a basic functioning unit
of a Fab for let's say a 28 nanometer
chip which is a mid-range so Nano uh so
as you decrease the nanometers uh which
is the uh more transistors are put onto
the chip and more computing power is
there so currently we are at five
nanometers three nanometers which is
if it is too expensive which is India
cannot afford to put so much Capital
into just one fabrication sap and and
very very few players are actually
involved in kind of doing this there are
not many players csmc Samsung Intel
these are the only major players in the
whole world who can actually do a five
nanometer or three nanometer uh
Fabrications facility itself so India
does not have that amount of capital and
they have not been able to actually
attract
in big form to set up any kind of of uh
of fabrication facility in the country
from what you're saying about how much
it would actually cost to create the
especially these high-end chips do you
think it's very or rather less likely
than that we're really going to see any
of the really state-of-the-art high-tech
being produced in India in the coming
years and is that more more likely to
stay in in Taiwan for example for the
time being
yes yes definitely it's not going to
come to India anytime soon uh and it's
not because it's concentrated with like
very very uh like it's just two or three
forms across the world and this
technology also
uh it's not easily transferable because
you can't just say that oh I'll give you
uh I'll tell you how to do it and you
can do it because there's so many other
factors that come into the city yeah so
there is so many uh dependencies which
have been created and India cannot like
like you know plug holes into all of
them right now they kind of have to
focus their resources on their strength
which is their comparative advantages
also in the in the in the value chain
actually quite intrigued to understand
how this is going to affect the job
market because semiconductors is a huge
business and even at whatever level
you're talking about if it's entering
the Indian market that is probably going
to take a big chunk of the job market
isn't it I mean are we going to see less
rate of unemployment because of this do
you have any idea how the government
plans are as far as employment is
concerned
uh so I mean that's the thing right so
uh these in each part of the value chain
you kind of you need different required
skill sets also so for especially
manufacturing you need a experience
labor you need kind of uh people who can
who have the uh like they they're well
well educated enough to understand how
to work
um manufacturing equipment like a
fabrication equipment itself but for an
assembly uh uh or testing or a packaging
part you do not need that kind of like
educated like not only that level of
Education in your labor as itself it can
be uh they can be like is this just low
cost labor uh and that is why India can
kind of get into that that than this and
especially in design it's very very um
it's very very technical right so these
are basically Engineers who have come
out or just come out of college are
looking to contribute to you know the
semiconductor industry and all they all
the um opportunities they have now are
either directly with the US like
basically non-indian firms or with
uh Services uh firms where there are
there are a lot of semiconductor Design
Services firms in the country wherein
they take a project of the uh bigger
players right so that Texas Instruments
are Intel or something they they say we
will take up the your project and we'll
design it for you and they'll hire
Engineers uh from colleges and the
universities to do that so
uh that's the thing India needs a
thriving domestic uh industry of design
firms itself which we do not have right
now so uh once we can get that up and
running then it will be it'll be uh yeah
it will create a lot of the employment
opportunities for engineers itself
um and if if uh they end up actually
building a Fab that will actually give a
lot of employment to manufacturing labor
right so probably we're going to see
more investment in training in the
coming years and it might not happen all
of a sudden it will take a lot of time
but there would be more jobs the way I
understand it thanks a lot uh it was
very insightful it was Fab
thanks a lot for your time thank you
thank you I think definitely the biggest
takeaway for me from that was how this
is very much a marathon and not a Sprint
and it's going to take so long to build
up those kind of expertise when you
think of the Decades that it's taken
Taiwan and I think it's really going to
depend now on where India decides to
invest that opportunities are there we
heard from Arjun whether it's
opportunities for engineers or even for
manufacturing labor but the Focus right
now it seems or the biggest potential
immediate short-term potential is design
and it depends on on how and to what
extent India really jumps on that now so
it really depends where and to what
extent India decides to invest in these
different areas that's right and I think
what I really understood is that
multilateralism is the need of this
industry so you would have one player
who's good at designing like you just
said there's another one who's actually
got the raw material yet another one who
can do the testing and Manufacturing
there would be someone else with the
Manpower but there can't be one player
who can do everything so it has to be
multilateral and one can't really strive
to be self-sufficient that's my one
takeaway and the other thing is when it
comes to jobs which was our question in
the beginning that jobs will be created
but probably in another decade or so and
not instantly now we've understood the
technicalities and he being an
electronic engineer I think he's really
made us understand the technicalities
really well but let's try and figure out
the politics that's happening behind
this whole technical business for that
let's bring in our next guest so to
understand the intricacies between India
and Taiwan relations I have my next
guest here who's harsh pant he is the
vice president of Observer Research
Foundation ORF in New Delhi welcome to
globalizer now Kate and I we've been
talking about iPhone production we've
been talking about semiconductors and we
know that since this September iPhone
then in fact new iPhones are being made
in India I'd like to begin by asking you
how do you really see this is it it's
safe to say that this is already part of
the shift away from dependency on
china-centered supply chain
I think it's it's the beginning of of
China plus one track in some ways in
supply chain diversification and we know
that we live in an age where
geoeconomics is being shaped by
geopolitics and the the sense that you
cannot be over dependent on any one
particular country and in particular
China I think has has changed the
dynamic of the supply chains uh the way
we think about Supply chains the way we
think about restructuring them and
balancing them and increasingly there
has been this idea that India is perhaps
one of the few countries that provides
the economies of scale in ways that a
few countries uh few other countries do
when you look at when you look at the
shift away from China so I think a lot
of the companies are interested in that
uh in looking at India through that
through a newer lens and I think India
also wants to be part of of a news story
in global geoeconomics where it presents
itself has a credible production
household number of themes that India is
interested in like uh is strengthening
its domestic manufacturing base
providing alternative uh production
incentives to to its own companies as
well as welcoming foreign companies to
come and invest in India I think that
that has begun to take shape to what
extent it goes forward how extensive and
detailed that process is that remains to
be seen but certainly I think we are
beginning to look at things in a
different way and India remains at the
heart of this new supply chain
restructuring so before we get into that
a little bit more I just want to jump to
one of your papers uh in the summer you
published an article in foreign policy
where you wrote public enthusiasm and
semiconductors do not make a bilateral
relationship I'm just wondering if you
could expand on that a little bit more
for us and explain exactly what you
meant by that
I think what what we meant by uh by that
is uh look there is a there's a great
degree of Interest today in Taiwan as
far as India is concerned Indians have
begun to look at Taiwan uh as a nation
that is very capable that has a
remarkable job when it comes to covet
management and is increasingly at the
heart of contemporary geotechnology and
emerging Technologies and and I think
that interest in itself is producing a
greater sense of anticipation about
these ties and on the other hand you
have uh you know this whole debate about
semiconductors and and and supply chain
restructuring about semiconductors and
whether semiconductor partnership
between India and Taiwan can be the
nucleus of a broader partnership but
what in fact we were arguing in in that
piece was that India needs to look at
Taiwan more holistically because Taiwan
and what what happens in and around
Taiwan in the coming years and decades
will also determine the future balance
of power in what we now call as the
indo-pacific and unless
um you know India is more vocal unless
India is more politically active in
engaging with Taiwan I think there are
going to be you know this public
enthusiasm and this newfound interest in
semiconductors will will pay some
dividends but not to the extent that
perhaps many people in India anticipate
now I'd like to ask if India keeps
getting closer to Taiwan the trade
relations are anyway they are getting
better and if I were to quote from your
paper you've written that bilateral
trade with Taiwan stood at 5.7 billion
dollars in 2020 and it continues to grow
and we're not only talking about private
Taiwanese companies who are trying to
invest in India but it is also at the
government's level that both the
countries Taiwan and India they're
trying to come closer I want to
understand can that be seen as a
deliberate attempt to irritate China
well you know there are two things one
is of course India's a relationship with
Taiwan which where trade and cultural
ties have have long been part of India's
engagement with Taiwan India has a
cultural center Taiwanese Indian
Cultural Center trade and Cultural
Center in Taiwan Taiwan has a similar
Center in India both countries interact
at a level of educational exchanges
People to People ties uh trade and and
commerce as well as broader cultural
interactions so there has been uh you
know a sense that India needs to
cultivate and continue to engage Taiwan
as an entity even in the context of one
China policy of that India has uh you
know articulated but the other side of
this is that in in recent years uh
certainly uh many in India have
questioned India's continued adherence
to One China policy when many in India
believe that China in fact never adheres
to one India policy and that has been a
criticism that even uh uh Indian policy
makers have made openly that it cannot
be the relationship between India and
China cannot be uh you know uh has to be
more reciprocal it cannot be a one-way
Street where India continues to give in
whereas China continues to demand more
from India by unilaterally changing the
Status Quo along the border by
challenging India across its periphery
Etc so I think that articulation that
that sense that India needs to push back
in certain ways has also now given a new
Dynamic to India Taiwan relations uh
certainly uh India would like to
increase uh the engagement with Taiwan
and Taiwan in particular also is
interested in increasing its engagement
with the country like India because as I
mentioned uh you know apart from China
there are few other countries apart from
India that can give Chinese Industries
whether they are semiconductors in
semiconductor industry or the
electronics Industry the kind of econ
enemies of scale and that perhaps you
know a big market like India or a big
country like India can provide I wonder
though traditionally uh India has always
tried to keep equidistant in a way
between different powers different
blocks while still being able to be part
of some uh Cooperative organization so
to speak
so I'm wondering how do you think these
new technological and economic ties
between India and Taiwan might affect
this Balancing Act of dailies
uh I think uh you know when it comes to
China today uh uh there is no you know
uh there is uh there is no attempt to
hide India's frustration uh New Delhi in
New Delhi uh policy makers are
frustrated are anxious uh and I think
ordinary uh people uh in India are also
very worried about Chinese behavior and
what happened in uh in the galwan valley
uh in in uh in 2020 uh where there was a
major scuffle between the two sides and
uh you know soldiers on both sides uh
died uh first time in decades when there
was violence on the border has really
shaken the the Indian perception of
China in in the past also there were
differences and there was an
acknowledgment of differences but the
fact that we now have a very volatile
border with China where where there is
violence where there are deaths where
there is a sense of apprehension of of
what might come and that has I think
changed the nature of this relationship
fundamentally so I don't think there is
any question that India would would not
take those actions that are needed to
protect and preserve what India believes
are its core interests vis-a-vis China
and China has been also pushing India a
number of fronts what we have seen in
the last few years is India getting
closer to like-minded countries in the
indo-pacific whether it is the
quadrilateral security dialogue with the
U.S Australia Japan whether it is
conducting military exercises with
like-minded countries or whether it is
giving us a signaling to China that it
is willing to engage Taiwan much more
substantively than before if only to
make a case to China that India also
have has some cards on the table it is
not as devoid of options uh in case
China becomes more aggressive or more
assertive and in case China becomes more
aggressive now chances are that there
could be armed conflict in the Taiwan
Strait so hypothetically talking if that
were to happen if China about to use
military force against Taiwan how would
India position itself now Kate has just
said she called it a balancing act how
would India balance itself in in the
world order
I see I think it all depends on I think
a lot depends on China's Behavior over
the coming years if China continues to
be this assertive this aggressive
you know this uh you know the kind of
behavior that China is pursuing Visa of
India today if that continues where
China does not even acknowledge Indian
sensitivities then I think India will be
more strident both in the criticism of
Chinese Behavior as well as in its
support for Taiwan the question is uh
you know what other countries are going
to do because India in and of itself
cannot change the dynamic vis-a-vis
Taiwan unless other countries other
democracies other like-minded entities
in the region unless European Union
unless the US start
becoming more vocal about Taiwan I don't
think India can change the fundamental
reality of Taiwan being uh you know a
very small country
near a behemoth like China and that will
have implications for Taiwanese future
so so I think a lot will depend on how
the International Community how the
Democratic World in particular reacts to
what happens in Taiwan Straits I mean
looking at the market right now looking
at the supply chains right now do you
think that EU will speak against China
if uh hypothetically again if that
situation were to arise
well it's very unlikely and we have also
seen uh you uh you know uh making taking
a very very uh balancing uh attitude uh
I think Kate used that word means for
India but I think it equally applies for
Europe Europe has been we have had
German Chancellor visiting China despite
criticism from from some of Germans
Germany's closest allies from within the
government Etc so I think we know that
there are divisions within within
European Union within Europe about the
future of their of the relationship with
China and therefore what what I was
saying was that it would depend on what
the Western worlds what the Democratic
world's reaction to What happens in
Taiwan is when when there is when there
is a crisis the more united the the
Democratic world is the better the
chances are that one can provide some
some support some credible support to
Taiwan uh but I think certainly given
the the dependencies given the supply
chains at the moment and given that
strategic or economic decoupling is
really a long-term process it would take
time and even India is aware of that
India for example since 2020 has been
trying to make a case or has been trying
to reduce its dependence on China but
it's it's very difficult the numbers are
uh India's uh trade with China is very
high uh even today and it's trying to
change that Matrix but it's going to
take a long time and I think the same
will apply to Europe I just want to jump
on a different point that you mentioned
there very briefly which is this
economic decoupling which makes me want
to get back actually to the the
geopolitics of these semiconductors
um I mean they've really seen as being
so key to the Future and in the coming
decades whether it's through mastering
you know emerging Technologies like Ai
and really you know they will play such
a key role in determining and
determining who really has the upper
hand in in the 21st century uh you know
if you look back to the United States
just a couple of years ago already in
2020 the U.S imposed this embargo on the
export of American semiconductor
technology to to all Chinese
semiconductor firms we had even more we
saw more
restrictions and Export controls also
related to semiconductors imposed just a
couple of months ago in October of this
year so I'm wondering effectively this
is you know in this example it's the us
trying to stop the flow of American
Technology to China I'm wondering what
is India's place in Washington's plan
right now
well I think uh
India is increasingly
um and of course as you mentioned the
emerging Technologies are at the heart
of this geopolitical contestation
between U.S and China and U.S as you
mentioned very rightly has been making a
case not only uh within its in its
domestic legislation but also to its
partners and allies that we need to
re-look at our relationship with China
when it comes to emerging and strategic
Technologies and therefore a lot of
constraints are being put into place a
lot of a framework is being put in place
uh that would make it virtually
impossible
um for uh for uh China to leverage uh
these kind of technological advantages
from the U.S system now uh I think India
on the other hand is is seen as a vital
partner of the us and we have seen India
becoming a beneficiary of this move away
from China uh factor that that we are to
sing so you've said a couple of times
that you cannot be dependent on any one
country there's need to reduce
dependency and you just mentioned that
India U.S and India EU relationships
will have to be worked on now I would
like to wrap up with this that recently
Xi Jinping has said that in one of his
speeches
he had said that the country needs to
become self-reliant and China needs to
strengthen in the field of science and
technology now that is also something
that the Indian Prime Minister likes to
say a lot that there should be this
self-reliant India so when it comes to
semiconductors my question is is it even
practically possible to be self-reliant
to be completely independent of others
in this business
yeah I don't think so and I think that
is why uh uh you know India for example
is so keen on Taiwan and and a
relationship with Taiwan at this
juncture in particular when it comes to
semiconductor industry uh because uh
certainly with all the emphasis on
self-reliance uh and uh as you mentioned
the idea actually has been that India's
manufacturing has been has been getting
decimated over the last few decades and
this is the story of other major major
economic Powers as well where we have
seen uh China's manufacturing capability
growing whereas the manufacturing
capacities of other countries virtually
getting or almost disappearing and and
that has I think reignited this debate
as to how do we balance our economies
better so that the sustainability of our
economic engagement uh you know the the
sort of lopsided economic engagement
that the world that many countries have
had with China can be reduced and I and
that is where this thing about
self-reliance comes from because India
like many other countries wants to
rebuild its manufacturing base now
certain in certain sectors that's going
to be easy uh in certain sectors India
is has moved ahead but in certain
sectors as you rightly mentioned like
semiconductors it's not possible to do
that particularly in the short to medium
term and uh you have to create an entire
ecosystem that can generate uh you know
the the industrial infrastructure for
that and that's not going to happen
overnight and therefore Partnerships are
going to be important but Partnerships
again uh would mean that how do you
define those Partnerships where do you
go for those Partnerships and and I
think most of the world is recognizing
the fact that instead of putting all
your eggs in one basket it's better to
diversify and in particular you go to
those countries where you feel there is
uh you know there is a greater degree of
trust and transparency I think
unfortunately we're gonna have to wrap
up there but thank you so much harsh for
your for your time and for your insights
thank you thank you very much thank you
I think if one thing is clear certainly
Partnerships and diversifying of reading
the two key words to take away from this
right now is there's this economic
decoupling from from China not only
um by countries like Germany and the us
but this is really on a global scale and
there's loads of huge challenges there
as well but of course at the same time
we have the situation where you have
these growing tensions between China and
Taiwan and as we heard from both of our
really great guests we can see already
how fragile the the supply chain is in
creating these chips and so what a
disturbance in the in the manufacturing
of these chips in Taiwan for example
were there to be any kind of Chinese
aggression towards Taiwan what that
would mean on a global scale and it
really underlines again after what we've
already seen with the shortages at the
height of the pandemic just what an
integral part of of life and and how
after our future really depends on on
these chips you know whether it's from
you know everyday Electronics from our
phones to our toothbrushes even to
Advanced weapons so these chips and and
and semiconductors really are going to
be so important in determining uh the
future of you know not only what we use
every day around the home but also you
know global politics as well that's
right and our security our future really
depends on these tips that's correct and
if I were to take the example of Russia
for example since the war in Ukraine
started now America has made sure that
Russia does not get any chips that has
got anything to do with America whether
it is design that was done in America or
whether the chips were produced there or
just about anything and so today it's
like you know in India you say if I can
again use couple of words that I always
do in Hindi in India they say
that means uh that when you have
animosity with someone you make sure
that they don't get water they don't get
food but in this case I understand when
you have to make sure that some economy
should not strive then you're going to
stop giving semiconductors to them and
another thing one sentence that's going
to stay with me was what Hersh said that
new Partnerships they're not going to
happen overnight so that is going to
take time but whatever time it takes
whatever course it takes this is really
going to decide our future semiconductor
chips the tiny tiny tiny semiconductor
chips and anything huge impact and it's
going to be Fab and that's something I'm
going to remember so what do you think
what are you going to remember what did
you learn out of this podcast do let us
know if you have any questions if you
are watching us on YouTube then please
leave a comment below and get in touch
with us yeah of course if you have a
question as well you can on exactly how
security policy is or could affect your
and our lives then of course you can
also let us know by sending us an email
well to Global eyes dw.com we'd love to
hear from you next time goodbye